Film Courage: Is there a way to
avoid writing on-the-nose dialogue?
Jen Grisanti, Speaker/Story/Career Consultant,
Author: Yes, with dialogue obviously the best
thing you can do with dialogue is recognize
when you go out and you listen to conversation
people do not speak in complete sentences and you
record or you think about how are people speaking
in a way that feels feel authentic and dialogue
also reveals so much about things like character
traits and flaws and life phases so you want to
think about things like where is this character
in their life and when I look at the life process
is my dialogue reflective of where this character
is is my dialogue reflective of the want is my
dialogue reflective of the conflict that the
character might feel internally is my dialogue
reflective you always want to think something in
scene work you always want to think of is the car
is the scene revealing character while advancing
plot how do you write emotion without stating
emotion that's a great question emotion all comes
down to the setup of things like the dream the
biggest fear the audience feeling the void so when
you enter the story you want to think about the
idea of what is making the character stuck when we
enter the story and the feeling of what is making
the character stuck when we enter the story goes
into the setup of the emotional arc so you're not
hitting on the head what the emotion is instead
you're giving us a sense through subtext of the
void and then you're escalating the emotional
arc through understanding what is getting in the
way with the void and how the pursuit can help
the character process the past so that they can
move toward the future goal I'm thinking too about
want how do you how do you state want in dialogue
like I'm thinking back to the to the White Lotus
yes and the Jennifer Coolidge character has found
this this young woman who will just sort of listen
to her and be her sounding board but she's also
manipulating her and it's revealed in these little
tells about the business oh I don't have to we'll
talk about that later right but she she throws it
out and then she takes it away again yes yes the
I think with dialogue the there's a value in the
subtext of the want like you're describing I also
think that the want is something that you can hit
on the nose with the character just declaring I
want blank and I I think that that I have seen
that done incredibly well where it's great for
the audience because you clearly know what the
character wants so there's a value in the subtext
as long as we don't miss the want and there is a
value in the dialogue sometimes defining the want
on the nose for the audience yeah so you could see
both wants were very clear the the Jennifer kulage
character wanted to be needed and then the other
woman was hoping to make it out of this sort of
Hotel treadmill of working behind the scenes with
these these clients and so both both wants are
very present in the dinner conversation they I
think they' gone out to dinner yes and yeah and
you could see in those wants and that that's a
great thing to to illustrate you can see in the
wants of those two characters that it has to
with Jennifer Coolidge it has to do with what's
making her stuck and how the dream and being in
business with the other woman could be an answer
for her and for the other woman Jennifer's being
stuck and needing to go in a direction could be an
advantage for her so when you look at the want I
always say when you're setting up co-protagonist
we need to understand how one is the answer to
the other's dilemma and that comes down to want
like when you look at the show hacks and you have
a sense of Deborah's character and the idea of of
her being in the life phase where work is stopping
because of her age and you contrast that with
a younger character who's asked to help punch
up her Jokes which could help her dilemma and
then with the younger character you also have
work is stopping because of something she said on
Twitter that caused her career that was blossoming
to suddenly stop so you have two characters who
their wants are in connection and they are the
answer to the others dilemma what should a writer
know about monologues or should a writer of try to
avoid monologues in their film or or TV or play
I love that question I think that so many story
experts will say no more than four to five lines
of dialogue so of course when you hit a monologue
You're Going way over that if the monologue serves
the intention of the story there is value in the
monologue when you look at Aaron Sorkin who could
have a full page or two pages worth then it and
it serves the story in such a brilliant way that
brings you to a sense of depth and understanding
of the character there's a value however just know
that the rule of thumb is you should have four to
five lines of dialogue so the value of brevity
the value I often tell writers you want to look
at these big huge chunks of dialogue and figure
out how you can say the same thing and less words
what is the focal point of the intention and how
can you hit the same depth because the consequence
of too many words is you lose the focal point
certainly in comedy when you're looking at
Cadence and you're looking at the cadence when you
have over three to four lines of diet dialogue you
lose that cadence the joke gets buried because
there are so many words so so there's a value
in the monologue if it serves the intention but
there's also a value in can you say something with
the same amount of depth without so many words
yeah I'm thinking one one place and this is an
old reference but Say Anything with John Cusack
yes and where he goes on this sort of tirade
about he doesn't want to produce anything you see
this guy's like anti-corporate, anti-consumerism,
he shows who he is in his monologue yes and here
he's got this this woman that he's in love with
who's from like more of a wealthy family serves
show incredibly well that's a great example that
is done incredibly well because it serves the
story and the character and the audience because
it brings them into that desire right so it shows
it shows kind of who he is it's very limited and
what he wants to do there's not a lot of room
but he knows he likes being with her but they
they kind of come from these opposite worlds
and yes and the polarity going into that yes.